ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครู Arty
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนเย้กลับมาเจอกับครัวตี้
ครูพี่เอ๋ในช่องคอม prensa เบิ้ลไทยนะ
ครับถ้าวันอะไรคะเออ
สวัสดีไม่จบปกติเราจะเจอกันทุกวันจันทร์
และวันนี้ไม่ใช่วันจันทร์
วันนี้เป็นวันอังคารวันนี้วันอังคารได้
ครับวันนี้เราผู้เอกในสีชมพู
วันนี้วันอังคารครับวันอังคารนะคะ
วันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันอังคารที่ 16
ครับวันนี้ 16 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนนี้เดือน
สิงหาคมเดือนสิงหาคมให้ชีพ.ต.ต.เท่าไหร่
คะปีพ.ศ
2565 ครับ
2560  5 ปีเมื่อปีคศอะไรอ่ะข้อ
2022 นะครับ
2022 ได้แล้วครับ
Lounge ตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงเวลาใช่ไหมคะ
โอเคตอนนี้อะวันนี้เราเจอกันเร็วขึ้นไม่
ได้เจอกัน 20:00 นเหมือนเดิมนะวันนี้เรา
เจอกัน 13:00 น
ขอยังไม่บ่ายสองโอ้โห 52 นาทีอ๋อบ่ายโมง
52 นาทีนใช่ครับพูดอีกอย่างไว้อีก
10 นาที 14:00 น her ใจกับอีก 8 นาที 10
นาทีประมาณประมาณ 10 นาที
52 เท่าเหลือ 8 นาทีว่ากูเองไปเลยนะคะขอ
โทษอีก 8  5 นาทีบ่ายสองแล้วอีกแม่ดีนะคะ
ๆ 8 นาที 14:00 นกูอ่ะนะครับผมที่ไม่คะ
เออแข็งแรงดีครับแห่งแรงยังแข็งแรงดีอยู่
แรง
สวัสดีให้กูเองง่วงนอนทำไมบอกสิบนาทีไม่
นาทีนะคะเลอนิดหน่อยนะ
โอเคค่ะครูอาทิตย์ 5 วันนี้วันนี้เป็นยัง
ไงมีเรื่องอะไรมาเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังกับ
วันนี้และเรื่องทำธุระนั่นแหละอ๋อ
ละเพราะว่านักเรียนอ่ะว่าอยู่ประเทศไทย
บางคนก็อยู่บ้านขับบางคนก็อยู่
อพาร์ทเม้นท์
บางคนก็อยู่คอนโดอ๋อขับคอนโดคือถ้าเป็น
เป็นอพาร์ทเม้นท์เนี่ยก็โอเคไม่ค่อยมี
ปัญหาภาพ Apartment มีปัญหาก็อาจจะขอ
เปลี่ยนห้องอ๋อใช่ๆเปลี่ยนห้องได้ขับอัน
นี้น่ะถ้าอยู่เบอร์โทรล่ะเปลี่ยนได้ไหม
กำลังเช่าหรอเธอ
หนาก็วันนี้นักเรียนจริงๆนักเรียนก็อาจจะ
เช่าคอนโดอยู่หรือซื้อคอนโดนะคะแล้วแต่คน
ที่นี่นะเวลาที่เราอยู่คอนโดเนี่ยเราก็
อาจจะมีปัญหาในห้องอ่ะแก
อายอาจจะมีปัญหา
ห้องน้ำมีปัญหา
ประตูมีปัญหา
มีปัญหาเยอะนะเราเจอปัญหาถ้ากูอาร์ตี้
อาร์ตี้ดูปัญหากลัวกูเอกก็อยู่คอนโด
เหมือนกันใช่ไหมครับอยู่คอนโดค่ะโอเคมี
ปัญหาอะไรครับผู้ชายที่บ้านน่ะเขาชอบก็
อยู่คอนโด
ที่บ้านมีผู้ชาย 1 คนไม่ใช่คนอีดอกชอบ
อยู่คอนโดยิงเข้าด้วยเออ
เพราะว่าถ้าซื้อเนี่ยเราอยู่ไม่สบายมัน
เปลี่ยนไม่ได้อ๋อ
ขับจะเช่าแล้วหรอไม่ชอบเปลี่ยนได้น้ออ้าย
k5 ๆค่ะเดี๋ยวกูเอ๋จะจะให้ดูนะคะว่ามี
ปัญหาอะไรมีปัญหาอะไรครับที่คอนโดของที่
ครูเอ๋อยู่จะเป็นมาละเห็นไหมคะคุณอาตี้
ครับตอนนี้เห็นแล้วครับโอ้รูปอะไรครับ
เนี่ยอ๊อดข้างหน้าห้องน้ำขอ
พูดอย่างนี้ความตีกับกูเองว่าให้ดูครับ
ออกก่อนนะคะว่าให้ดูลักษณะของคอนโดของกู
เอกก่อนใช่ไหมออยจะอ่านได้ค่ะวิธีที่ห้อง
มี
คอนโดจะเป็น
โดนเล็กๆกลับคืนเล็กๆมีความไม่ทันน่ะฉัน
จะน้อยเขาหยุดซอยซอยเล็กๆก็จะมีอยู่แค่
ประมาณ 8 ชั้นอ๋อ
8 ชั้น 1  2  3  3  4  4  5  5  6  6  7
800 โอเครีบแอดฉันแล้วกูเออยู่ชั้นอะไร
ครับ
2  3  3  4  4  5  5  6  7  8  4 อยู่
ชั้น 5 ค่ะอ๋ออ๋ออยู่ชั้น 5 โอเคว่า
ค่ะแล้วก็ปรากฏว่าห้องเนี่ยที่ห้องน้ำ
เนี่ย
ห้องน้ำนักเรียนคะห้องน้ำเขาจะเป็นแบบนี้
เขาจะเป็นแบ่งเป็น 2 ห้องนี้ห้องอาบน้ำ
ตรงนี้ห้องสู้ร่วม
ห้องอาบน้ำตรงนี้ก็เราก็เรียกว่าค่ะเปียก
นะเนาะ
กลับห้องน้ำจะมีแบบท่องส่วนที่เป็นคลื่น
แห้งคือไม่โดนน้ำใจครับก็ส่วนนี้จะเป็น
ห้องน้ำที่เปียกน้ำอ่ะตรงนี้เขาก็จะมี
กระจก
นะคะ
จะวัดเขมาถ่ายรูปมาให้เห็นแค่นี้
ถ้ากดละข้างหน้าห้องน้ำครับหน้าห้องน้ำ
คือตรงนี้ตรงนี้จะมีประตูขอเป็นสีน้ำตาล
แล้วกันตรงนี้ค่ะประตูเนี่ย
ด้านตรงเนี้ยค่ะ
ขอที่อยู่ด้านนอกด้านนอกห้องน้ำใช่ไหมไม่
ได้อยู่ในห้องน้ำเฮ้ยน้ำข้างนอกเป็นแบบ
นี้ค่ะ
อันดับแรกเลยตัวเองคิดแบบนี้ไหมคะว่าติด
ที่ว่าอะไรครับคิดว่า
ท่อน้ำ
คิดว่าข้างล่างหวีดท่อคุณหมอคิดว่าในข้าง
ในเนี้ยข้างในเนี่ยที่อยู่ข้างหลังเรียก
ว่าในผนังนี้ใช่ไหมครับมีข้อน้ำอ๋อว่าท่อ
น้ำเนี่ยรั่ว
[เพลง]
ฮะโอเคเดินลงไปก็ได้นะแดกขี้เกียจมัน
เนี่ยนะอย่าไม่อยากเจอคนเยอะๆเออโทรไป
ง่ายกว่าครับไม่ต้องลงไปก็คุยแป๊บเดียว
ได้ก็ลืมไป
โทรมาห้องห้อง 2148 โทรมาอีกแล้ว
รับสาย
สวัสดีครับมิติครับสวัสดีค่ะน้องห้องน้ำ
ที่มีปัญหาขอห้องน้ำมีปัญหาอะไรครับข้าง
หน้าห้องน้ำน่ะที่ผนังอ่ะพี่ปัญหานะน้อง
ชอบตรงเนี้ยะ
เจอปูนอ่ะค่ะโอนมันคลองออกมาอ๋ออ๋อปูนค่ะ
คุณแม่น้องตรงข้างหน้าห้องน้ำอยู่ด้านนอก
ห้องน้ำใช่ไหมครับหรือทางด้านในด้านนอก
ของน้ำข้างนอกห้องน้ำห้องน้ำมันเป็นเป็น
กระเบื้องปิดเอาไว้แต่ข้างนอกมาเป็นปูน
แล้วก็ทาสีสีเทานะคะน้องอาบแล้วมีน้ำออก
มาเหรอครับมีน้ำออมันบวมมาค่ะตรงนี้มัน
บวมแล้วมันมันบวมออกมาแล้วมันเป็นสีขาว
อ๋อ OK พี่ไม่รู้ว่าท่อน้ำเนี่ยอยู่ข้าง
ในแล้วร่วงหรือเปล่าไม่รู้ว่าแปลนคอนโด
เป็นยังไงร้องนั่งขึ้นมาดูได้ไหมคะก็ได้
ครับอันนี้เป็นมานานหรือยังครับพี่เพิ่ง
เห็นได้เห็นเขียนก็แรกมันนิดหน่อยพี่ก็
ว่าไม่เป็นอะไรแต่ตอนนี้มันเยอะขึ้นนะคะ
เยอะขึ้นที่น่ากลัวว่าน้ำรั่วหรือเปล่า
ได้ครับเดี๋ยวผมติดต่อติดต่อช่างของคอนโด
ให้ครับแล้วก็จะให้ขึ้นไปดูที่นี่คุณ
พี่เก๋คะพี่เอ๋ถ้าพี่เอ๋สะดวกสะดวกให้
ช่างขึ้นไปดูวันไหนครับพอดีวันนี้สอบพี่
สอนแล้วก็แฟนพี่ทำงานอยู่ห้องนี้ได้ไหมคะ
พรุ่งนี้ได้ครับบ่ายสองโมงประมาณบ่าย 2
นะครับโอเคเดี๋ยวผมนัดช่างไว้นะครับให้
ช่างของนิติเนี่ยขึ้นไปดูให้เบื้องต้น
ก่อนนะครับว่ามีปัญหาอะไรแล้วอาจจะต้อง
แก้ไขยังไงเดี๋ยวเราไปดูกันที่นั่นนะครับ
ไม่ค่ะได้ค่ะครับผมว่ายซองนะครับเดี๋ยว
พี่ 2 โมงค่ะพี่จะรอในห้องนะคะโอเคได้
ครับผมหาขอบคุณมากค่ะพรุ่งนี้นะคะวันพุธ
บ่าย 14:00 นจะได้ครับผมครับวันพุธที่ 17
นะคะเออครับผมได้ครับวันพุธที่ 17 บ่าย 2
โมงแล้วเจอกันครับขอบคุณค่ะครับสวัสดี
ครับสวัสดีครับ
โอเคตอนนี้นัดเอ่อนิติได้แล้วใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้บ่ายสองให้นิติผ้าก่อตั้ง
ขึ้นมาดูค่ะ
ก็
หล่อขับรอหรือจนวันต่อไป
ตอนนี้หมายถึงพรุ่งนี้แล้วบ่ายสองแล้ว
สมัยบายยังไม่ถึง 14:00 นตอนนี้ 13:10 นๆ
50  52 นาทีตอนนี้รอก่อนปล่อยแต่นาทีนัก
เรียน
มันวันนี้วิธีนี้พรุ่งนี้โอเคครับพรุ่ง
นี้นะคะอ่าเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้ตัดไปเป็นพรุ่ง
นี้เดี๋ยวกู Arty เป็นช่างเหรอก็เป็นคู๋
นะคะเออโอเคโอเคหัวตีโทรไปตึกๆๆๆๆ
เข้ามากดกริ่งเลยหอมพออยู่ข้างในอยู่แล้ว
มากดพอนั้นแล้วว่าบ่ายค่ะน้องปิงหน่อง
ติ๊งหน่องกว่านี้กลัวตีเป็นช่างนะนิติไม่
ได้มาแล้วคนที่เป็นช่าง 5 และวันต่อไปใช่
ป่ะถามกว่านี้วันพุธนิติไม่มามาแต่ช้าง
ซ้ายครับกดกดอ่อนครับที่หน้าห้องอร์ดฮอตๆ
หูข้าอาบออกเสียง
ใส่หน้ากากอนามัยก่อนเออ
นะครับเปิดประตูสวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะพี่
เอ๋เล็กใช่ไหมครับไปค่ะเป็นช่างใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ครับผมเป็นช่างจากเมื่อวานนิติแจ้งมา
ว่าครูเอ๋มีปัญหาห้องน้ำหน้าห้องน้ำมีรอย
น้ำซึมออกมาใช่มั้ยใช่
น้องมาดูนี่เดี๋ยวพี่ดูโอเคเดี๋ยวผมตาม
เข้าไปครับอยู่ตรงไหนครับเนี่ยค่ะน้องคะ
ดูตรงเนี้ย
ตามที่ใหม่อ๋อ
ตรงนี้เนี้ยค่ะน้องมันมีท่อน้ำอยู่ข้างใน
ไหมอ่ะเอ่อเอ่อตรงด้านนี้เนี่ยไม่มีท่อ
น้ำอยู่ด้านนี้นะครับท่อน้ำจะอยู่ด้านใน
ตรงข้างตู้อาบน้ำข้างในแล้วคงนี้จะมีน้ำ
ไม่มีท่อน้ำครับไม่มีท่อน้ำแต่ทำไมมันพอง
เหมือนมีน้ำอยู่ข้างใน
แสดง
เดี๋ยวผมขอค่าเดินเข้าไปดูข้างในนิดนึง
ครับโอเคอ๋อตรงนี้มันตรงกับห้องอ่าห้อง
อาบน้ำพอดีตรงนี้เป็นส่วนเปียกใช่ไหมครับ
ใช่แล้วเวลาที่เวลาที่เราอาบน้ำเนี่ยน้ำ
มันก็จะซึมเข้ามาซึมเข้ามาตามรอยของ
กระเบื้องมันจะมีรอยต่อของกระเบื้องใช่
ไหมครับแล้วน้ำซึมเข้ามาแล้วก็ซึมออกมา
ทางด้านนอกนี่ครับ
รอยต่อแบบนี้หรอคะๆใช่ครับน้ำเวลาที่เรา
อาบน้ำก็จะมีน้ำใช่ไหมนั้นก็จะซึมเข้า
เป็นรอยรอยต่อกระเบื้องแสดงว่ายาแนวมี
ปัญหาล่ะคะๆอาจจะเป็นไปได้ว่ายาแนวอ่าและ
ตัวยาแนวยาแนวเก่าแล้วมีปัญหาให้ครับก็
เลยทำให้น้ำซึมเข้าไปออกอีกด้านหนึ่งของ
ของผนังห้องครับขอแล้วอย่างนี้พี่ต้องทำ
ยังไงอ่ะอ๋ออันนี้นะครับถ้าจะให้แก้ให้
หายเลยนะครับไม่ต้องการจะเป็นเกิดปัญหา
ขึ้นอีกเนี่ยก็ต้องปูกระเบื้องใหม่ครับ
เอาต้องรื้อห้องน้ำตอกใหม่ทั้งหมดเลยเอ้อ
ทางด้านด้านในด้านที่มันซึมออกมาขนาดด้าน
นี้ครับอาจจะเหลือแค่ผนังด้านเดียวก็ได้
นะครับถ้าขาดอยากจะเหลือแค่ด้านเดียว
ไปครับแต่ก็หรือด้านเดียวได้แต่ถ้าหรือ
แล้วเนี่ยสีก็จะไม่เหมือนกันนะแต่ว่ากู
อยากได้สีเดิมสีเดียวกันทั้งห้องน้ำเขตก็
จะต้องเปลี่ยนกระเบื้องทั้งห้องน้ำเลย
ครับอาเราจะเกิดว่ามันเหลือแค่ทำงานแล้ว
สีไม่เหมือนเดิมมันแตกง่าย
แปลกไม่เหมือนกันครับอ๋อถ้างั้นก็ถ้าทำ
น่ะหรือดูหนังโป๊ปูตั้งใหม่ขอให้เวลา
ประมาณกี่วันค่ะโอ้ถ้ารื้อแล้วก็ปลูก
กระเบื้องใหม่หรอผมคิดว่าน่าจะใช้เวลาสัก
ประมาณ 2 วันครับ 2 วันใช่ครับ 2 วันออก
มันประมาณ 6 ตารางเมตรน้องโอ 6 ตารางเมตร
ห้องเป็นห้องน้ำเล็กๆนะครับโอเค 6 ตาราง
เมตรก็หรือใช้เวลาหรือ 1 วันแล้วก็มาปู
อีก 1 วันค่ะแล้วก็น่าจะนะคะคะหรือออก 1
วันแล้วก็ปลูกอีกวันหนึ่งเสร็จในได้เลย
ไหมคะก็อาจจะต้องทิ้งไว้อีกสัก 2 วันครับ
เพื่อให้กาวยาแนวแห้งแล้วก็ปูนแห้งครับ
ถึงไอ้เข้ามาใช้งานได้ตามปกติครับก็แสดง
ว่า 4 วันประมาณ 4 วันใช้คำทำ 2 วันแล้ว
ก็วันที่ 4 จึงใช้งานได้ใช้พี่ก็ต้องออก
ไปอยู่ข้างนอกก่อนใช่ไหมหน้าก็ถ้าสะดวก
ที่ออกอยู่ข้างนอกและก็ได้ครับ
เขาก็น่าจะใช้ห้องน้ำไม่ได้เลอะชายใจห้อง
น้ำกว่าจะยังใช้ไม่ได้ครับช่วงที่ผมเหรอ
หรือแล้วก็ทำใหม่ครับค่ะวันเนาะแล้วน้อง
คิดยังไงคะอ่าสำหรับห้องน้ำห้องเดียวนะ
ครับเดี๋ยวผมตีราคาเหมาเลยก็ได้ครับค่ะ
เหมาก็คือผมจะรวมให้ทั้งหมดเลยมีค่าปูน
ค่ายาแนวค่าหรือถ้ามีค่าปูนปูนกาวชายมี
ปูนกาวที่เราใช้ปูกระเบื้อง
อันใหม่เข้าไปอ้าแล้วก็มียาแนวที่เรายาลง
ไปตามร่องของรอยต่อของตัวเรื่องแต่ละแผ่น
ครับเพื่อป้องกันน้ำซึมเข้าไปแต่ว่าหน้า
มันต้องทาสีใหม่ด้วยนะต้องทาสีก่อนที่จะ
ปูยาแนวครับอ่าแล้วก็ซ่อมซ่อมด้านนอกที่
น้ำซึมออกมาครับก็ต้องทาสีใหม่ค่ะขับเออ
อยู่และกระเบื้องด้วย
ทั้งหมดนี้
ประมาณเท่าไหร่คะเออผมตีราคาประมาณประมาณ
9000  500 ครับ
1,500 บาทจะเอาพันห้าครับโดยประมาณนะ
ครับรวมทั้งหมดนะคะรวมทั้งหมดเลยคือเหมา
ทั้งหมดเลยเก้าพัน 500 บาทได้ค่ะอาหาร
9504 วันนะที่ต้องย้ายไปอยู่ข้างนอกครับ
อยู่โรงแรมหรือบ้าน
อาเดือนนี้เนี่ยใจอ่าจะยังทำไม่ได้เป็น
เดือนหน้าได้ไหมคะอ๋ออ๋อได้ครับเดี๋ยวคู๋
เช็ควันที่พร้อมที่จะให้เข้าเดี๋ยวผมอ่า
เดี๋ยวเราคุยกันอีกทีนึงว่าจะทำวันไหนแต่
ว่าก่อนที่จะทำเดี๋ยวเราอาจจะต้องมีการ
ซื้อของพืชเตรียมเอาไว้ก่อนครับก็อาจจะ
ซื้อกระเบื้องไว้ก่อนซื้ออุปกรณ์ไว้ก่อน
แล้วเดี๋ยวว่าจะเบิกเงินล่วงหน้าก่อนใช่
ไหมคะใช่ครับต้องมีเบิกเงินล่วงหน้าไป
เหมือนครับเอาเบิกอ่าสัก 50 เปอร์เซ็นต์
ก็ได้ครับก็ประมาณ 4,500 บาท 4,500 ก่อน
กับเรื่องเอาไปซื้อกระเบื้องก็เดี๋ยว
เดี๋ยวผมให้อ่าคู๋นะครับเลือกลาย
กระเบื้องก่อนครับว่าอาหารอยากได้
กระเบื้องลายไหนนะครับเหมือนเดิมเลยค่ะ
เอาลายเดิมใช่ไหมครับสีเดิมเลยโอเคเดี๋ยว
ผมไปหาดูในท้องตลาดก่อนว่าเรายังมีลายนี้
ขายอยู่ไหมเพราะบางทีอาจจะไม่มีแล้ว
เดี๋ยวถ้ายังไงผมแจ้งมาอีกทีนึงนะครับว่า
มีลายเดิมหรือเปล่านะครับได้ค่ะอืองั้นก็
ก็เดือนหน้าวันวันนี้วันที่เท่าไหร่นะอ้า
วันนี้วันที่ 17 ครับวันนี้วันที่
เดือนพฤษภาคม
หน้าคู่เอ๋สะดวกจะเข้ามาทำวันไหนเดี๋ยวกู
เอกแกล้งของใหม่ทีนึงเป็น 10  10 ประมาณ
17  17 มิถุนายนได้
โอเค 17 มิถุนายนใช่ไหมเดี๋ยวนะหาได้ค่ะ
โอเคเออ
ว่าง7มิถุนาล่ะครับผมเคลื่อนเดือนนี้มัน
ไม่ใช่เดือนมิถุนายนนะครับ
มาก่อนได้ว่าก่อน
โอเคโอเคเล่นเดือนเรื่องผ่านแล้วทำไปโอเค
อ่าได้ครับเดี๋ยวเราเจอกันวันที่ 17
มิถุนายนครับ 5  17 มิถุนายน 17 มิถุนายน
ครับนักเรียนขาก็เอกก็นัดกับช่างนะคะนัด
ประมาณพฤษภาเราก็มิถุนายนน่ะให้ช่างเข้า
มาทำเมื่อแอบตั้งเข้ามาทำอาหารก๋วยเตี๋
รู้ไหมถึงนาเป็นไงครับ
คือทางน่ะเป็นช่างของคอนโดก็แปลว่าพอถึง
เวลาเนี่ยคอนโดเปลี่ยนธีมนิติอ้าว
แม่เปลี่ยนเดี๋ยวเปลี่ยนธีมนิติแล้วช่าง
ก็เปลี่ยนด้วยเหรอครับทั้งก็เปลี่ยนไปค่ะ
อ๋อ
หน้าช่างต่อไปจ่ายเงินจ่ายเงินไปแล้วไหม
แต่งงานไปแล้วก็โอเคเขาว่าติดต่อช่างได้
ช่างบอกไม่เป็นไรพี่เดี๋ยวผมก็เข้าไปทำ
ถามราคาเดิมมั้ยอ๋อถ้าเดิมเออโอเคไม่มี
ปัญหาหายก็ตกลงกันไว้แล้วใช่มั้ยก็ต้อง
ราคาเดิม
เสร็จแล้วเนี่ยครับโอเคออกไป
นอนที่โรงแรมก็ขับเข้ามาดูช่างทำวันแรก
กว่าสิช่างมาช่างรื้อ
ใช้กับเครื่องลึกของเก่าที่น้ำซึมออกก่อน
เออนี่คือรูปนี้ในคือทำห้องน้ำแล้วนะคะ
แต่ว่าลืมกำลังรื้อของมาไว้ข้างนอกเออก็
มาทำตัวนี้นะคุยให้ดูรูปเขาก็ก็ทำกับและ
หรออาหารทาสีใหม่ใช่ไหมเอาสีอะไรนะ
ขูดสีเก่าๆคูณ 4 เก่าที่มันที่มันพองออก
ก่อนเนอะขับพูดสีเก่าออกเอกกะถามเขาวัน
นี้ทำอะไรคะช่าง
อยากรู้มันก็บอกคู่สิออกครับเออครับแล้ว
เสร็จแล้วเขาก็มีมีสีนะคะเราจะมีสีสีแบบ
นี้ก่อนสีที่พาลงไปอาบเขาเรียกว่า
แหละลองพื้นเธอเป็น 4 รอบพื้นครับสีรอง
พื้นแล้วก็สีที่ 2 นะคะ
สีที่ 2 เป็นสีทับหน้าเป็นสีสวยๆที่ทาน
แล้วจะได้สี
หมู่บ้านอย่างที่เราชอบทำสีที่สองก็จะ
เป็นสีนี้เลยนะครับเอกรัตน์ดูนะดูเสร็จ
อ่ะเพราะถึงปูกระเบื้องปูพื้น
ปูพื้นอีกก็เห็นกระเบื้องที่เขาเอามาเป็น
ไงครับมันเป็นแบบนี้ครู Arty เออตัวนี้
เรยวะกานิโต้อ๋อครับสีนะตรงตรงกับห้องน้ำ
ห้องเดิมสีเหมือนกันนะครับแก่คู่เอก
น้องๆพี่รู้สึกว่ามันลื่นหรือป่ะอ๋อมัน
ลื่นใช่ไหมมันลื่นมันลื่นอะลื่น
ช่างก็บอกว่า of พี่มันก็เหมือนที่ผนัง
นี่ไง
เธอนะแล้วมันจะลื่นนะพี่จะล้มมั้ยเฮ้ยย
ถ้านักเลงเข้าใจลื่นนะคะคือคือมันสไลด์ไป
ได้มันเออใส่อ่ะมันลื่นเวลาเหยียบแล้วมัน
ยืนไม่ได้ใช่ไหมเวลามีน้ำเปียกเวลาอาบน้ำ
มีสบู่ด้วยก็จะลื่นเยอะเลยที่นี่เรือนและ
เอ้อถ้าใช้ตรงข้องที่ไม่เปียกมันก็ยัง
ลื่นนะถ้าไปอยู่ห้องที่เปียกอ่ะกูโง่เธอ
เจอกับผม I ลื่นแน่ๆๆดีก็เอ่อ
น้อง
เอาไงดีคิดใช่ไหมคะเอออันนี้ช่างช่างช่าง
ก็อาจจะบอกว่าอันเนี้ยผมหาที่ไลน์เหมือน
กันลายเหมือนกันที่กูเอกเถอะนะแต่ว่ามัน
เป็นมันเป็นแบบลื่นเป็นแบบผิวเรียบครับ
มันไม่ใช่ผิวหยาบที่เอาไว้ปูพื้นผ้าปู
พื้นต้องเป็นผิวหยาบในพระเจ้าเวลาเดินก็
จะไม่ลื่นไงเออ
จะโชคดีอะไรรู้ไหมคะว่ายังไงครับโชคดีที่
อ่ะตอนที่ช่างจะขึ้นมาน่ะจะต้องไปรับช่าง
ที่นิติใหม่อ๋อ
ก็ต้องบอกนิติว่าเอ็งจะเอาช่างมาทำห้อง
น้ำมิติก็บอกโอเคเดี๋ยวจะขึ้นไปดูแล้วก็
จะเอาประกันน่ะเขาจะมีคนที่เคลมประกัน
ห้องน้ำขึ้นมาด้วยอ๋อมี 2 ณวันที่สอบครับ
ราดนิติก็ขึ้นมาสามคนมีประกันมาอีกหนึ่ง
คน
ก็เป็น 4 คนแล้วก็ช่างอีก 2 คนถาม
คนที่ประกันก็คิดว่าคุยทำห้องน้ำเดี๋ยว
เขาจะจ่ายเงินใช่มั้ยเขาเช็คนะฮะอันนี้นะ
คอนโดมีปัญหาโอเคจะจ่ายค่าซ่อมเขาก็ดูเขา
ก็บอกว่าพี่
แพนเนี้ยใช้ที่ห้องน้ำไม่ได้ครับหมอเพราะ
ประกันเขาจะต้องดูว่ามันถูกต้องหรือเปล่า
ที่จะเอาอ่ากระเบื้องปูผิวเรียบที่ปูผนัง
มาปูพื้นนะครับแบบนี้ประกันไม่ยอมประกัน
ไม่ยอมนะฮะไม่ได้ห้องแห้งก็ไม่ได้ห้อง
เปียกไม่ได้ 100% เออครับ
ค่ะอันนี้อันตรายไม่ได้คุยคุยเสร็จใช่ไหม
ครับ
เฮ้ยสรุปคุยเสร็จประกันไปกูเอกก็คุยกับ
สร้างหอดูแล้วไง
เอกก็เบาะโอเคทำยังไงได้ช่าง
ขอ
ช่างก็เสนอว่าช่างแนะนำว่ายังไงครับทำยัง
ไงดีที่พี่ซื้อกันลื่นมาถ้าได้ขอ
ก็อ่านกันรื่นเป็นเป็นอ่าเลขอะน้ำยาทา
แล้วไม่ให้ลื่นอ่ะมาทาได้
เอกก็เลยเปิด Google ดูค่ะครู Arty ซื้อ
ใช่มั้ยฮะอ่าจะซื้อโอเค
กันลื่นน่ะ 4,000 บาทเป็นยังไงครับโอ้โห้
ราคา 4,000 บาทโหโหแพงจังประมาณนะคะหลัง
4000 บาทอาจจะมีบวกหรือลบโอเคนิดหน่อย
ปาร์ตี้คะค่ะอันนี้จะซื้ออะไรคะระหว่าง
กันกับกลับเรื่องใหม่ขอคนที่คิดว่าถ้า
กระเบื้องใหม่พื้นที่ห้อง 6 ตารางเมตรก็
น่าจะถูกกว่า 4,000 บาทครับถ้าซื้อ
กระเบื้องใหม่
โอเคน้องไม่เป็นไรไม่เอากันลื่น
R เป็นซื้อกระเบื้องใหม่ดีกว่าถ้าจะซื้อ
กระเบื้องใหม่นะคะเราพระเอกก็เลยไปซื้อ
เองผัวตีอ่อนเอาลายที่มันเป็นผิวหยาบใช่
ไหมไม่ใช่ผิวมันไม่ใช่ผิวเรียบเวลาไปซื้อ
เราก็ต้องไปบอกเขาที่ที่ร้านวัสดุก่อ
สร้างเรียกว่าวัสดุก่อสร้างค่ะซื้อ
กระเบื้องขอบกระเบื้องปูพื้นน้ำๆอ่าเป็น
คะมันจะมีพื้นที่เป็นแบบนี้นะคะครู Arty
น่ะอาบอยากแบบขรุขระเหรอกับอย่าแบบเรียบ
อ่ะอาบจะมี 2 แบบนะครับและแบบเนี้ยมันทำ
ความสะอาดยากอ๋อนะครับพรุ่งนี้ค่ะเซ็เด้อ
เอาแบบไม่ลื่นแต่ก็ไม่ไม่มีลุงกลับก็เลย
บอกเขาว่าขอแบบนั้นกูอีกก็เลยได้วันนี้มา
ส่วนจริง
มีค่ะเราจะหมดเวลาใช่ไหม 4 นี้ก็ได้สีนี้
มาแล้วก็ไม่ลื่นแต่เป็นแผ่นเล็กอีกก็ถาม
มีแผ่นใหญ่ไหมคะ
ก็บอกไม่มีกระเบื้องปูห้องน้ำจะมีแผ่น
เล็ก
ลื่น
ไปแบกมาค่ะ
ไม่ตัวเอง
เราก็เอาน้องช่างน้องน้องๆๆเอาอันนี้ปู
แทนเธอนั้นไม่เอาน้องพี่ในกระเบื้องมาละ
น้องลงไปยกมาให้พี่หน่อยเอาอันนี้ปูแทน
เออโอเค
ครับ
นะ
กูได้ค่ะคุณอาตี้ครับแล้วก็อย่าแนวเวลา
ปลูกเขาก็จะใช้ตัวนี้ค่ะอุ่นเช็คปูนกา The
Sims  N นะครับสำหรับปูกระเบื้องลงไปได้
มันจะเร็วใช่ไหมคะอะไรครับแล้วก็จะทำให้
ติดทนนานด้วยเพราะมันเป็นกาวจะเป็นกาว
ซีเมนต์นะครับแล้วมันก็ทำให้น้ำนะมันไม่
ไหลลงไปข้างล่างๆครับไม่ซึมลงไปห้องข้าง
ล่างด้วย
[เพลง]
แล้วก็เสร็จแล้วเขาก็ยาแนวให้
หนักนี้ก็คือยาแนวชายป้องกันน้ำซึมเข้า
ตรงขอบขอบของกระเบื้องฮะตัวนี้จริงๆเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรนะคะครูอติอ้าเขาเรียกกาวยา
แนวครับกาวยาแนวนะคะๆนะตอนนี้ก็คือการทำ
ยาแนวๆครับอุทยานแนวนี้ช่างต้องเก่งเนาะ
เหรอต้องเก่งนะก็ต้องต้องทำงานเป็นครับ
อ่ะดูไม่ต้องเก่งมากก็ทำได้ครับแต่ก็ต้อง
ทำงานเป็นใช่มีทำไม่เก่งน่ะโอ้โหอ่ะปวด
หัวตายน้ำก็จะอาจจะซึมเข้าไปได้หรือว่า
บางครั้งเราก็การทำความสะอาดเหมือนก็จะ
ได้ทำได้ไม่ดีนะครับแล้วก็อัฐิหรือไมค์
คู่เอกใจอะไรเธออะไรครับอ่ะอันนี้อ่ะค่ะ
โถสุขภัณฑ์นะค่ะอ๋อแนวตรงนี้ใช่ไหมคะได้
รอบๆต้องยาแนวด้วยคะทำไปเสร็จนั่งอีกทำไม
มันยุค
อ้าวพี่ก็คิดว่าตัวหนักกับสิอุ้ย
เอาไม่เกี่ยวถึงนะโอเคแล้วเป็นไงครับก็กด
ว่าดูเอ่อเดือนที่แล้วเอกก็เลยมาดู
ยาแนวมันแปลกแล้วก็หลุดออกมาเออ
ก็เลยต้องให้ช่างใหม่มาทำอ๋ออ๋อยาแนวเข้า
ไปใหม่ใช่ไหมครับให้ยาแนวใหม่ตอนนี้โอเค
โอเคแล้วโอเคไม่เป็นไรแล้วน้ำก็ไม่ซึมออก
มาข้างนอกแล้วใช่เหรียญสวยเดิมและโอเคน้ำ
ไม่ซึมแต่มันอยู่
ตอนนี้น้ำไม่ซึมอันนี้พยานแอร์วันนี้
เสร็จเจออะไรต่อไปไหมคะท่อน้ำท่อน้ำที่
ไหนครับเป็นยังไงจะมีเค้าเนี่ยเป็นท่อน้ำ
ทิ้งด่านก็เป็นไหนก็เป็นแพะสี่เหลี่ยมแบบ
นี้อ๋ออ๋อเป็นท่อน้ำทิ้งก็โอเคเวลาเรา
ล้างห้องน้ำน้ำก็จะไหลลงมาในท่อตกนี้ใช่
ไหมใช่ห้องคิดไหลเข้าไปห้องค่ะ
เนื่องจากอ่ะตัวนี้ห่ากับเรียกว่าเขา
เรียกว่าอะไรนะรอเด่นเนาะเออกับประเด็น
ที่จะปิดปิดตรงท่อน้ำทิ้งตรงเนี้ยกราบมัน
ก็เขาเอาออกปั๊บเค้าซ้อยาแนวเก่าออกขอ
แม่อะเขา
และยาแนวใหม่
ถึงแล้วก็ทำอะไรไม่รู้ทำให้ไฟเด่นมันแตก
มันเป็นพลาสติกมันแต่ก็ครับน้ำก็ซึมค่ะ
กูอะติ้งซึมออกไปข้างนอกไม่ลงไปในท่อน้ำ
ทิ้งใช่ไหมใช่
ทางคนที่ 2 เป็นคนบอกว่าอ้อพี่มีปัญหาอัน
นี้อันนี้อันนี้อันนี้
อ่า
ซ่อมอีกครั้งหนึ่งโอเคกำลังอัตรานิถาหา
ตัวนี้ไว้ห่า
ทา
ตรงตรงท่อน้ำทิ้งเท้ากาวยาแนวเอาไว้เรายา
แนวเอาไว้ทั้งหมดก่อนรอ
ไม่ทำงานที่บ้านแล้วก็ให้ช่างเข้ามาซ่อม
พี่ 2 วันครับเพราะวันเหมือนเดิม
คือวันที่ 1 อ่ะเอาออกแต่เราต้องปล่อยให้
แห้งที่ 2 ใส่แล้วก็วันที่ 3 เข้ามาใช้
งานได้
เพราะ 2-3 วันค่ะ
คอนโดต้องระวังถ้าเป็นบ้านไม่ต้องระวัง
มากเป็นบ้านก็ต้องระวังครับแต่ว่าถ้าเป็น
บ้านเราก็ไม่ต้องไม่ต้องติดต่อกับนิติเรา
ทำเองได้เลยแล้วตัดสินใจเองได้เลยคิดเอง
ทำเองได้เลยในครับเพราะว่าถ้าเป็นห้องน้ำ
ชั้นล่างแล้วมีมีมีมีรั่วนิดนึงน้ำจะลง
พื้นข้างล่างเลย
ค่ะลงไปห้องคนอื่นใช่ไหมไม่ใช่ห้องเราถ้า
เป็นคอนโดนะจะลงคนอื่นแต่หากเป็นบ้านน่ะ
เป็นบ้านแล้วพูห์ Arty ห้องน้ำชั้นล่าง
ถ้ามีปัญหานิดนึงน้ำมันไม่ลงข้างล่างก็
ไม่มีปัญหาอะไรไม่มีปัญหาอะไรใช่ฮะแต่มัน
จะไม่สวยเท่านั้นเองหรอเอ้อนะคะก็ได้นะคะ
นักเรียนคะโรงเรียนอยู่คอนโดเรามีปัญหา
นักเลงก็โทรหานิติได้ปัญหาแบบนี้แบบนี้ก็
บอกเขาว่าอ่ะซ่อมได้ไหมบ้านอย่างเขาซ่อม
ให้ได้มันมาทายาแนวตรงส่งห้องส่วนเขาก็
ไม่คิดเงินนะแต่ว่าถ้าซ่อมใหญ่ๆน่ะเขาถึง
จะคิดเงินนะคะทำก็ถ้าเป็นคอนโดใหญ่ๆนะเขา
ก็จะซ่อมให้เลยเออเอาะแต่แบตของเราต้อง
ซื้อเองนะหัวติเราต้องออกเงินค่าของที่
ต้องซื้อมาใช่ไหม
โอเคค่ะวันนี้นักเรียนก็รู้วิธีคุยกับ
ช่างขับคุยกับนิติแล้วเวลามีปัญหานะคะ
โอเคหมดเวลาแล้วก็หมดเวลาแล้วครับเดี๋ยว
เรากลับมาเจอกันใหม่เลยครับในหัวข้อต่อไป
เขาหน้าครับวันนี้เราสองคนต้องลาไปก่อนนะ
ครับค่าสวัสดีตอนนี้ครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีครับ
นักเรียนบ๊ายบายบายน